et pour en parler nous sommes avec
michel ruimy professeur à sciences po
spécialiste des marchés capitaux et de
l'économie monétaire bonsoir mais celle
rumi merci d'être avec nous alors
hongrie et pologne 1 qui ont exprimé
leur condition et reste unie alors
peut-on lié état de droit et intérêts
financiers de l'union européenne
alors première des choses qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que le ce veto n'a pas
encore été exprimés au niveau du conseil
européen c'est-à-dire l'organe
décisionnel il a été exprimée au niveau
des du comité des représentants
permanents c'est à dire des ambassadeurs
des états membres
donc on ne peut pas parler aujourd'hui
de veto officiel alors ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que cette question de la
pologne et de la hongrie pause
je dirais plusieurs questions première
des choses
il convient à mon sens de voir quelles
sont les valeurs et européennes et
quelles sont celles de l'état de droit
parce que tant qu'on n'a pas défini ce
que c'était ce qui est au coeur de
l'état de droit c'est à dire les limites
du pouvoir politique on arrivera à
aucune avancée deuxième chose également
sa pose aussi des questions de
mécanismes de prise de décision au
niveau de l'union européenne qui sont
toujours à l'unanimité des vingt-sept et
là l'idée ce serait de passer de
l'unanimité à la majorité donc c'est
vrai que cela pose des problèmes
malgré tout malgré tout dans cette
affaire ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
qu'il ya des possibilités de contourner
le veto
un première des choses c'est de
transférer le contenu du plan de relance
dans un accord international qui
pourrait être ratifiée par les 25 autres
états membres c'est ce qui s'était passé
avec la crise des dettes souveraines
avec la grèce lorsque l'on a t on est
passé par un traité international pour
établir un mécanisme européen de
stabilité de le pacte gt1 mais sinon il
ya aussi une autre possibilité c'est de
passer par une coopération renforcée
c'est à dire une procédure qui en fait
qui ne s'applique pas aux 27 membres
mais qui s'applique uniquement à ceux
qui le désirent c'est à dire que
généralement cette coopération renforcée
parce c'est quand on n'arrive pas à
avoir une ligne d'une unanimité
donc ce sont deux techniques qui serait
extrêmement facile à mettre en place
mais puisqu'il existe déjà un texte
négocié mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ça pose un problème pourquoi parce
que le principe de le mécanisme de
conditionnalité
comme il est déconnecté du plan de
relance pourrait s'appliquer à la
pologne et à la hongrie alors même
qu'ils pourraient ne pas bénéficier du
plan de relance
donc je pense que aujourd'hui on est à
des pains porter menteur mais presque
dans la mesure où il faudrait que
aujourd'hui toute la difficulté c'est
que chaque que les deux parties puissent
arriver à intégrer l'autre partie sans
que ça soit une défaite c'est que chacun
a mis face est une avancée l'un vers
l'autre
p'tain manière que l'on puisse arriver
dont notamment la première des choses
pour bruxelles serait peut-être
bien de mettre d'abandonner la procédure
dite de ce qu'on appelle la critique que
c'est qui qui sont notamment pour la
violation présumée de l'état de droit
donc je pense que s'il ya un effort la
commission à ce moment là à ce moment là
la pologne et la hongrie pourrait
s'arranger on pourrait avoir une sortie
vers le haut on est bon on n'est pas à
nos premiers désaccords
l'union européenne avec les pays donc
avec la hongrie et la pologne qui en
font partie aussi
qu'est ce qu'on doit en tirer comme
conclusion aujourd'hui le fait c'est que
aujourd'hui l'europe est devait on va
dire montrer au niveau de hauts niveaux
de passer aux états unis par exemple une
autonomie stratégique et de défense face
à l'eshs une puissance commerciale
aujourd'hui l'europe et sommet d'une
certaine manière d'affirmer ses valeurs
démocratiques et de voir un peu ce qu'on
entend pas ce que c'était des mots il
faut avoir un contenu maintenant
d'autre part en même temps il sera à mon
sens difficile de se passer de la
pologne et de la hongrie parce que ce
sont des pays importants et ça pourrait
ouvrir une boîte de pandore dans la
mesure où tant qu'on a pas être spécifié
ce que c'était qu'un état de droit et
des valeurs européennes
et bien tout pourra s'y mettre et c'est
toujours en état de crise en situation
de crise qu'on précise les mots et les
précisions donc je pense qu'il y aura
une avancé encore plus en avant avec
cette crise pour préciser certains
éléments qui étaient encore très
imprécis je pense pas qu'on aille
jusqu'à l'éclatement de l'union
européenne merci à michel remis d'avoir
été avec nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage